Hey, David. So it turns out Hunter
Biden is now being investigated.
So now what will this be, a cloud over
Joe Biden for his entire presidency?
I believe the answer is no. Here's why
I don't believe so. To back up the story
back in the pre-election part of twenty twenty,
this outrageous conspiracy was put together
which alleged this is like a blend of all the
different things. Hunter Biden, Joe Biden's son,
needed to get some laptops with really sketchy
stuff on them repaired. So he flew across the
country from the West Coast to the East Coast and
brought these three laptops while drunk directly
to a particular repair shop at which the person
doing the repairs and taking the laptops in was
legally blind. And it's unclear how well he was
even able to see who was dropping off the laptops.
And then Hunter Biden, after flying across the
country to get these important laptops fixed,
left him there and never picked them up. And what
the repair guy did was instead of, I guess, just
trying to get the laptops back to their owner,
he went in and read Hunter Biden's private emails
on the laptop and was convinced that it was Hunter
Biden because one of the laptops has a Beau Biden
Foundation sticker on it. This is the so-called
laptop from hell, as it's been dubbed by Donald
Trump. Then the repairman found what was on there
so sketchy that he gave it initially, I believe
it was to the FBI. And when the FBI didn't do
what the repairman wanted done with the laptop
after months, the repair guy called Rudy Giuliani
and gave him the hard drive or laptop and the rest
is history. OK, so that's that's the story.
What is going on right now with Hunter? Biden
has nothing to do with that. Now, what would
Biden is in the middle of is an investigation
related to reportedly, I believe it's one
hundred and ten or so thousand dollars in
unpaid taxes. Hunter Biden says he's
cooperating fully with the investigation.
He believes he paid all the taxes he should
have and he's cooperating, period. So this has
nothing to do with the laptop from hell. First and
foremost. That's an important thing to remember.
And I don't think that I mean, listen, Republicans
have given the option. They'll do investigations,
they'll call for a special counsel, whatever.
But Biden certainly is not going to be part of
Joe Biden's administration. I know that we may now
because of Donald Trump, think, well, obviously,
Hunter is about to be a high level adviser to Joe
Biden. No, that no, that's that that's not going
to be the case. And as a result, I think that this
is not going to generate the sort of titillation
that many on the right are hoping. Now, I would
find it fascinating if Joe Biden came out and said
no one is above the law. People should get their
day in court and everybody should be subject to
investigation. If law enforcement believes
there's been wrongdoing, even if it's the
child of a president of the United States and step
completely out of the Hunter Biden thing, which is
going to be resolved in due course. And of course,
the implication of Joe Biden saying that would be
this also applies to Don Jr. and to Eric Trump and
to Ivanka and to Jared Kushner and whoever else.
The conspiracy theories about Hunter Biden will
explode. But I would be shocked if this became
what some in the conspiracy. Right. Are sort of
hoping that it will become. I
may be wrong and we will see